Donald Trump has famously said so many
times you must respect the flag you must
respect the national anthem you must
stand at attention during the national
anthem anything but total unflinching
devotion to the national anthem is
unpatriotic and now a video has leaked
of Donald Trump at his Super Bowl party
Sunday at mar-a-lago laughing fidgeting
pretending to do like he is conducting
like a conductor during the national
anthem pointing at people and at one
point where the video I'm going to play
cuts appearing to be actually starting
to sit down while the national anthem is
playing take a look at this video it's
like a new [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
suck it up new [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you might have noticed that the video
cuts when Trump appears to be just going
to sit down while the national anthem is
still playing but don't you dare kneel
during the national anthem if you're a
football player it actually looks like
the video was specifically edited to
remove Donald Trump sitting down during
the national anthem so what does this
tell us the entire salute the flag
respect the anthem stuff from Trump is
nonsense Trump can't stand still for it
he's fidgeting as much as a toddler
something seems very much wrong with the
guy but he's also making other people's
lives miserable over what they do during
the national anthem while he behaves
like a kid during it while he behaves in
the way he claims is disrespectful and
actually said get that son of a [ __ ]
out of here or whatever the case was
because of what people did during the
national anthem he's goofing around like
a bored toddler while foreigner Melania
Trump stands there with her hand over
her heart and tries to get Trump to
behave like an adult and again it does
seem like the behavior of someone on
some kind of upper like an adderall type
thing or some other kind of stimulant we
don't know we never know just imagine
for a second if Barack Obama was caught
on video behaving like this during the
national anthem it would be that
anti-american Muslim unpatriotic
foreigner Obama disrespecting the flag
and the anthem and the troops and Ronald
Reagan and everything's just being
disrespected if Barack Obama does it now
but it's Trump so who cares you know
what I thought when I saw this we are
definitely not in Kansas City Kansas
anymore if you know what I mean now even
more hilariously the video was posted by
a real estate agent for a Russian
American firm that often hangs out at
Donald Trump's mar-a-lago resort just
every detail is hilarious and tragic why
is a Russian always involved why are
Russians always hanging out at
mar-a-lago fixtures at Donald Trump's
events this is one of those things I
think I've learned when it comes to the
anthem it's only disrespectful if you're
a Democrat or you're black or you're a
football player but when you're a 73
year old
and president like Donald Trump it's all
totally cool to behave this way during
the national anthem the same people who
said they were disgusted by Colin
Kaepernick kneeling in protest during
the anthem say nothing about what Donald
Trump does in this video I actually
suspected this is really funny I
suspected when I saw this trumpets will
defend Trump they'll say Trump is not in
the room where the anthem is being
performed
Trump's at mar-a-lago watching the
anthem on TV it's actually being
performed in Miami at the Superbowl so
it's okay not to stand or to fidget or
to point at people and I decided it was
a risk but I did it I went into the
Trump Astana claves of the internet
yesterday and this is exactly what they
were saying guys you got to cool off
trump's not in the room where the anthem
is being performed if he did this in
that situation it would be disrespectful
trump's at mar-a-lago they're just
watching it on TV when football players
do it the anthem is being performed
there Trump and Mara Lago were watching
the anthem on TV so the rules are
different the etiquette is completely
different and Donald Trump is completely
exonerated but when a black football
player kneeled for the national anthem
that was too much once again I got
emails from people saying I have family
members with dementia when people in
their 70s appear to have this fidgety
sort of ADHD behavior it's not usually
ADHD it's usually some form of dementia
and once again we don't know we don't
know because no serious evaluation of
the president has been done